So, yes, just to recap what has just happened here. Bryce was traveling in Japan, bought a French clock in Japan from the 1900s. Well, no, technically the 1800s, which is the 19th century. Yes. And then traumatized the clock, which has a name and is now part of the podcast lore, Henri the Clock. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 178, recorded on April 17th, 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about Henri the Clock, Chunk Buy, and more. Do you know where I just was?
好的，那么，简单回顾一下刚才发生的事情。Bryce 在日本旅行时，买了一个 1900 年代的法国时钟。嗯，不，严格来说是 1800 年代，也就是 19 世纪。没错。然后他给这个时钟造成了心理创伤，它现在有了名字，成了播客传说的一部分，叫“亨利时钟”（Henri the Clock）。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 178 期，录制于 2024 年 4 月 17 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将聊聊亨利时钟、Chunk Buy 等话题。你知道我刚才在哪吗？
In conference, ACCU? No, no, I was in Dublin. Okay, yes, I am at ACCU in Bristol right now, but I was just in Dublin, which is technically the first ADSP road trip or the first Bryce and Connor road trip. You and I took a bus from the 2019 Belfast C++ committee meeting. We took a bus from Belfast to Dublin to go visit your sister. And if I recall correctly, I basically invited myself and you were somewhat uncomfortable about your plan, which was just to go hang out with your sister, and then suddenly you had this Bryce along with you. That's a pretty accurate description of what happened, folks.
在参加会议，ACCU？不，不，我在都柏林。好吧，是的，我现在在布里斯托尔参加 ACCU，但我刚才在都柏林，那严格来说是第一次 ADSP 公路旅行，或者说是第一次 Bryce 和 Connor 的公路旅行。你和我从 2019 年贝尔法斯特 C++ 委员会会议出发，坐巴士从贝尔法斯特去了都柏林去拜访你姐姐。如果我没记错的话，我基本上是不请自来，而你对你的计划感到有些不自在，因为你原本只是想去和你姐姐待在一起，结果突然多了个 Bryce 跟在你身边。伙计们，这确实是对当时情况的准确描述。
Yeah. Yeah, but no, I am in Bristol now. a pretty accurate description of what happened, folks. Yeah. Yeah, but no, I am in Bristol now. I was in Japan for the Japan C++ Committee meeting, and then I took a bit of vacation. I went to the beautiful art island of Naoshima in the Japanese Inland inland sea um we also spent some time in kyoto where i bought a uh a clock um a clock that is going to cause a great deal of difficulty for uh this podcast connor because this is a striking clock. It strikes every 30 minutes.
是的。是的，但没关系，我现在在布里斯托尔。伙计们，这确实是对当时情况的准确描述。是的。是的，但没关系，我现在在布里斯托尔。我之前在日本参加日本 C++ 委员会会议，然后休了个短假。我去了日本内海美丽的艺术之岛——直岛。我们还在京都待了一段时间，我在那里买了一个时钟，一个会给这个播客带来很大麻烦的时钟，Connor，因为这是一个报时钟。它每 30 分钟报时一次。
And it does not have a silent mode. So there are going to be times when we are recording and when the clock suddenly starts going off. And I have a small apartment. There's nowhere in the apartment that I can put the clock where it won't be audible. Can I ask a question? Yes. What prompts someone to... I got actually two questions.
而且它没有静音模式。所以当我们录音时，时钟可能会突然响起来。我的公寓很小，公寓里没有地方能放这个时钟而不让它发出声音。我可以问个问题吗？可以。是什么促使某人……我其实有两个问题。
I got two questions. I got lots of questions, but I'm only gonna ask two. My first question, and I'm gonna ask these in order and then you can answer in whichever order you want. First question, what prompts someone to buy a clock that makes noise every 30 minutes? And question number two, it never is quiet? Do you not plan on sleeping
我有两个问题。我有很多问题，但我只问两个。我的第一个问题，我会按顺序问，然后你可以按你想要的顺序回答。第一个问题，是什么促使某人买一个每 30 分钟就发出噪音的时钟？第二个问题，它从来都不安静吗？你难道不打算睡觉了吗？
anymore? I mean, it's a small clock. It's a French carriage clock, an 1890s French carriage clock. So it's maybe four or five inches tall and like two inches wide. Um, and maybe like three inches, uh, deep. So it's not, it's not a big clock. Does that have, does that have anything to do with how much noise it makes or, or cause that doesn't answer either question. Well, yes. I mean, if it, if it, If it was a larger clock, it would make more noise. My mother just returned to the hotel room. I guess worthy of mentioning, which is that my mother is here with me at ACCU.
我是说，它是个小钟。这是一个 1890 年代的法国马车钟。所以它大概四五英寸高，两英寸宽，大概三英寸深。所以它不是个大钟。这和它发出的噪音大小有关系吗？或者说，这并不能回答任何一个问题。嗯，是的。我是说，如果它是一个更大的钟，它会发出更大的噪音。我母亲刚回到酒店房间。我想值得一提的是，我母亲现在和我一起在 ACCU。
Does your mom want to be on the pod right now? Maybe. But let's close out the clock business. Right, so it's a small clock. But let's close out the clock business. Right. So it's a small clock. I mean, you want to know why would somebody buy a clock that chimes? And this is an excellent question because some viewers, listeners, some listeners, not viewers because this is not a TV show. Some listeners will recall that I have a dog who has made some appearances on the podcast.
你妈妈现在想上播客吗？也许吧。但让我们结束关于时钟的话题。对，所以它是个小钟。但让我们结束关于时钟的话题。对，所以它是个小钟。我是说，你想知道为什么有人会买一个会报时的钟？这是一个很好的问题，因为有些听众——不是观众，因为这不是电视节目——有些听众会记得我有一只狗，它曾在播客中出现过。
And one of the things that sets off the dog is the doorbell going off. Another thing that sets off the dog, amusingly enough, is the chime that the Lyft app makes when it successfully hails you a ride. And this noise that the Lyft app makes, it does not seem to respect silent notifications. It seems like they have a bug in their app where that particular noise does not pay attention to your notifications volume. It just uses your device-like media volume. And so I can't really mute it. And every time the Lyft app dings, every time I get connected with the driver, it dings and then the dog goes crazy.
让狗抓狂的事情之一是门铃响。有趣的是，另一件让狗抓狂的事情是 Lyft 应用在成功叫到车时发出的提示音。这个 Lyft 应用发出的噪音似乎不理会静音通知。它们的应用似乎有个 Bug，那个特定的声音不遵循你的通知音量设置。它只是使用你设备的媒体音量。所以我无法真正将其静音。每次 Lyft 应用叮一声，每次我连接到司机时，它就会响，然后狗就疯了。
And so presumably the dog is not going to like Henri. Henri is the name of the clock, if you were wondering. And yes, I gave the clock a name. This poor clock was traumatized being transported all over Japan and then back home. It's currently not in my apartment, but it's with a clock doctor because Honorea's got an ailment that requires some care. But it makes a very lovely sound. And I was just very charmed with the clock. I was very charmed with the vintage clock store that we got the clock from in Kyoto. We not only got that clock, we also got a small cuckoo clock, not one that makes noise, just a small German cuckoo clock that Ramona
所以大概狗也不会喜欢亨利。如果你好奇的话，亨利就是这个时钟的名字。是的，我给时钟起了个名字。这个可怜的时钟在日本各地被搬来搬去，然后又带回家，受到了创伤。它现在不在我的公寓里，而是和一位“时钟医生”在一起，因为亨利患有一种需要护理的疾病。但它发出的声音非常美妙。我被这个时钟迷住了。我也被我们在京都买下这个时钟的那家复古钟表店迷住了。我们不仅买了那个钟，还买了一个小布谷鸟钟，不是那种会发出噪音的，只是一个德国小布谷鸟钟，Ramona 很想要，因为我们买了那个更贵的钟，所以这个就免费送了。然后 Ramona 得到了一枚胸针表，听起来就是它字面意思那样。它是一枚可以别在衣服上的胸针，同时也是一块手表。我原以为我的伴侣会强烈反对买这个可爱但可能很烦人的钟。但没有，她觉得声音非常美妙且柔和，她不认为这会是个问题。所以等我们回家，等我从医生那里拿回亨利时，我们就会知道了。嗯，是的，一些更现代的古董钟会有静音模式，但这一个相当老，而且不是特别精致，所以它没有静音模式。所以是的，在晚上，你只能习惯它。
really wanted that got thrown in for free because we were buying the much more expensive clock. And then Ramona got a brooch watch, which is kind of exactly what it sounds like. It is a brooch that one can pin to their clothes that is also a watch. And I thought that there was going to be greater resistance from my partner on getting this lovely but potentially annoying clock. But no, she thought that the noise was very lovely and very soft, and she did not think that it was going to be a problem. So we're going to find out when we get home and when I get Henri back from Um, and yes, some like more, uh, more modern, if you will, um, antique clocks, um, will have a silent mode. Um, but this is a fairly old one and not a particularly fancy one. Um, so it does not have a silent mode. So yeah, at night, you just get used to it.
我是说，当我们在酒店房间里和它一起睡觉时，它真的没打扰到我们。所以，我必须发表一个免责声明，多年来我告诉过很多人，嘿，如果你在纽约，随时欢迎来我家借宿。我得提醒听众，这不是一个通用的邀请。如果你没有明确被邀请到我家借宿，这不适用于你。但如果你已经被明确邀请到我家借宿，你现在应该知道，如果你睡在我的公寓里，会有一个法国马车钟每 30 分钟发出一次噪音。所以这仍然是一个很棒的公寓。我仍然强烈建议你接受我的邀请。我几乎从不在公寓里，所以你可能会独享这个地方，但还有那个时钟。所以是的，简单回顾一下刚才发生的事情。
And I mean, it really didn't bother us when we were sleeping in a hotel room with it. So I mean, there's a disclaimer I have to put out there, which is that there's a lot of people who I have told throughout the years that like, hey, if you're ever in New York, feel free to crash at my apartment. And I should note, listener, this is not a blanket invitation. If you have not explicitly been invited to crash in my apartment, this is not for you. But if you have explicitly been
Bryce 在日本旅行，在日本买了一个 1900 年代的法国时钟。嗯，不，严格来说是 1800 年代，也就是 19 世纪。是的。它是播客传说的一部分，亨利时钟，现在正在纽约进行手术，Bryce 不在那里，因为他在英国。敬请期待亨利是否能挺过来。而且如果它每 30 分钟响一次，你可能会经常听到亨利的声音。我们通常一次录音超过 30 分钟。是的。
invited to crash at my apartment, you should now be aware that if you are sleeping in my apartment, there will be a French carriage clock that will be making noise every 30 minutes. So it's still a great apartment. I still highly recommend you take me up on the offer. I'm almost never in the apartment, so you'd probably have the place to yourself, but there is also the clock. So yes, just to recap what has just happened here.
我觉得他会没事的。他还在准确走时。只是他的报时装置现在有点卡住了。所以这个可怜的时钟，我们买了它，然后就在买下它的第二天，我们不得不坐火车，然后坐两趟巴士，再坐渡轮去那个岛。然后我们几乎每天都在不同的酒店，一直处于不断的移动和旅行中，带着这个需要保持直立且非常脆弱的时钟。
Bryce was traveling in Japan, bought a French clock in Japan from the 1900s. Well, no, technically the 1800s, which is the 19th century. Yes. part of the podcast lore, Henri the clock and is having surgery right now in New York, back where Bryce is not because he's in the UK and stay tuned to find out if Henri makes it. And also you'll probably be hearing from Henri quite often if it's every 30 minutes. And we typically record for more than 30 minutes at a time. Yes.
不能磕碰。这真是一场折磨。一个非常 Bryce 的故事。伙计，我一直在准备我的 ACCU 演讲，演讲的前提是“并行思考”（Think Parallel）。它旨在向人们传授你我一直在培养的并行编程思维方式。所以它旨在深入探讨特定的算法和数据结构。最初我提议这个演讲时，我打算做一个版本，涵盖所有基础知识。然而，事情并没有按计划进行。所以现在我将在 ACCU 展示的版本是“并行思考第一部分：扫描”（Think Parallel Part One Scan）。所以它不会涉及关于并行编程的各种不同主题，而是只涉及一个主题。这将是 90 分钟的扫描，我们将讨论如何实现扫描，如何使用扫描，以及关于扫描的各种事情。我对这个演讲非常兴奋。如果你是听众，我们在过去一年里在这个播客中讨论过的一些事情肯定会在演讲中出现。就在我从日本回来前的三四天，比如周日，然后我妈妈周二到了。然后周四我们飞往爱尔兰。所以我只有周日到周四这段时间来准备我的演讲。我已经做过这个演讲的早期版本，但我需要编写这个算法，这个你我讨论过一点的“Chunk Buy”算法。我需要写出来，然后为它制作幻灯片。而且我们还有晚餐计划，我几乎没有空闲时间。我得拆包和重新打包。但我有个好消息，虽然这需要我熬夜到凌晨 2 点。但在凌晨 2 点，我搞定了。我举行了一个小小的静音派对，因为那时，
I do think he's going to be fine. He was he's still keeping good time. It's just his striker. That's a little bit jammed right now. So this this poor clock, we we purchased this clock. And then like the day after we purchased this clock, we had to take a train and then like two buses and then a ferry to get to this island. And then like we were in a different hotel like every night and just in constant motion and traveling the entire time carrying this clock, which needs to remain upright and is very fragile
我母亲在沙发上睡着了。我的狗在沙发上睡着了。我的女朋友在床上睡着了。其他人都觉得我有点疯，因为我整天整夜都在忙这个，在晚餐时因为没能搞定这个算法而心烦意乱。我当时在我最喜欢的寿司店，我母亲和女朋友玩得很开心，聊着生活和非工作的事情，就像在好的寿司店应该做的那样。而我坐在那里，就像进入了状态，拿着一张纸和一个小笔记本，勾勒着数学公式之类的东西。她们只是礼貌地让我一个人待着，但我搞定了。我搞定了。而且
and can't be bumped. It was a whole ordeal. A very Bryce story. Man, so I've been working on my ECCU talk, which the premise for my talk, it's think parallel. And it's all, it's sort of like attempting to teach people the mindset that you and I have been cultivating for how to approach parallel programming. So it's meant to really be a deep dive into particular algorithms and data structures. And originally when I pitched the talk, I was going to like have it, I was going to do one version of the talk and it was going to sort of cover all the bases. However, that's not how things have panned out. So now the version that I'll be presenting at ECCU will be Think Parallel Part One Scan. And so instead of a talk that touches on a bunch of different topics about
Connor，当你看到这个算法时，它会让你大吃一惊。它很美。它真的很美。我也对它进行了基准测试，它很快。就像，自从去年我搞定那个“滚动归约”（rolling reduce）算法以来，我还没这么兴奋过。那个滚动归约算法可能又是另一个话题，我可能会做一个“并行思考”关于归约的演讲。所有这些滚动归约实际上真的是一种扫描，因为它是用两个扫描实现的。所以这个“并行思考”演讲系列可能全都是扫描。全都是扫描。这就是它的全部内容。总之，我很兴奋。我今天到了会议现场，但我根本没去参加会议，因为我需要真正完成幻灯片的制作。我现在大部分都准备好了。我对结果很满意。好吧，首先，恭喜你。其次，你说我们提到过 Chunk Buy
parallel programming, it will touch on one topic. It will be 90 minutes of scan, where we talk about how to implement scan, how we can use scan, all sorts of things about scan. And I am very excited for this talk. And if you are a listener, some of the things that we have talked about in this podcast in the last year will certainly come up during this talk. And right in the like three or four days before I got back from Japan, like a Sunday, and then my mom got in on a Tuesday. And then on Thursday, we flew out to Ireland. And so I had like between that Sunday and that Thursday to make my talk. I'd already given an earlier version of the talk, but I needed to like write this algorithm, this new chunk by algorithm that you and I've talked about a little bit. And I needed to like write it and then like make slides for it. And then like also like we had like dinner plans and like I had like no free time. I had to unpack and repack. But I got some good news, which is that it did require me staying up till 2 a.m. But at 2 a.m., I cracked it. And I had a little silent party because at this point,
几次。我们有一个完整的三部分系列，Chunk Buy，是的，第一、二、三部分。听着，伙计，我过去六周的生活一片模糊，就像我之前在日本，然后我在爱尔兰，现在我在这里，在某个时候我在纽约，我写了很多代码，做了很多事情。这简直是一团糟。但是的，我现在回想起来确实有一个三部分系列。我在那次录音中描述得很糟糕的算法，就是我现在已经成功实现的算法。所以比我最初预期的更棘手的是边界条件，是的，你可以用扫描来实现它，但你必须聪明地处理第一个元素和最后一个元素。
my mother was asleep on the couch. My dog was asleep on the couch. My girlfriend was asleep in the bed. And everybody else thought I was a little bit crazy that I'd been working on this all day and all night and had been just distraught during dinner that I could not crack this algorithm. I was there at my favorite sushi place, my mother and my girlfriend having a good time and chatting about life and non-work things as one should at a nice sushi place. And I'm sitting there just like in the zone with a piece of paper and a little notepad, sketching out math and stuff. And they're just like politely letting me be, but I cracked it. I cracked it. And
而且，如果你在平铺它并进行单次扫描，你必须做一些技巧来处理每个瓦片的开头和结尾。有一次，我想，Cub 中有一个叫“块不连续性”（block discontinuity）的东西，我想如果你在 Cub 中做这个，你会这样做。但我只是想直接用标准 C++ 编写。
Connor, this algorithm, when you see it, it is going to blow your mind. It's beautiful. It is beautiful. And I benchmarked it too, and it's fast. It's like, I haven't been this excited since I cracked that rolling reduce algorithm last year. And that rolling reduce algorithm will probably be a whole other, I'll probably do a think parallel like reductions talk. All of that rolling reduce is actually really kind of a scan because it's implemented in terms of two scans. So this whole think parallel talk series might just all be scans. It's all just scans. That's all the that's all it really, really is. Anyways, I'm excited about it. I got into the conference today and I did not go to the conference at all because I needed to like actually finish making the slides. And I've got most of it together now. And I'm pretty happy with the result. Well, first of all, congratulations. Second of all, you said that we've mentioned Chunk Buy
所有这些算法，我演讲中的一切都是纯粹用标准 C++ 并行算法实现的。但是的，我最终能够搞定它的那个方面。我不确定，当我们谈论 Chunk Buy 时，我知道我提出了一个解决方案，关于我们如何纠结于我们正在深入研究 Reduce By Key Thrust 算法，以及它们是否是用……我想我们确定它是用 Inclusive Scan By Key 实现的。然后我们讨论了你是否可以用 Reduce 来实现它，我想我们就是在那儿停下的，对吧？对，好吧，事实证明你可以用扫描来做 Chunk Buy。而要实现 Chunk Buy 扫描，必须意识到一个关键直觉，
a couple times. We had a whole three-part series chunk by yes part one two and three look man it's all my my life for the past six weeks is all a blur like i have been i was i was in japan then i was in ireland now i'm here a lot of like at some point i was in new york i was writing a lot of code doing a lot of things. It's been chaos. But yes, I do recall now that there was a three-part series. And the algorithm that I poorly describe, I think, in that recording is the algorithm that I have now successfully implemented. So the thing that made it trickier than I had initially anticipated is the boundary conditions, which is that, yes, you can implement this with a scan, but you sort of have to be clever to handle the first element and the last element.
那就是首先你必须意识到你可以用多个扫描来实现 Chunk Buy。比如如果我能做三次扫描，三次非常简单的扫描，我就能做 Chunk Buy。它可能效率不高，但三次非常简单的扫描我就能做到。你知道，我可以做一个扫描来算出会有多少组，这些组的索引是什么，然后我可以做一个扫描来算出每一组的开始和结束，或者我可以做一个扫描来算出开始，一个扫描来算出结束，所有这些都是相当简单的扫描。然后你面临的唯一棘手的部分是，我如何编写一个能同时做所有这三个扫描的单一扫描？而且还要负责设置标志位。这就是最具挑战性的部分。因为你必须定义你自己的新数据类型。然后你必须在该数据类型上定义一个操作符，一个在该数据类型上的归约操作符，来做正确的事情。我卡住的一个地方是关于单位元操作，我定义了我的数据类型，然后定义了我的加法操作符，我定义的方式让它能工作。然而，要定义一个能与并行扫描正确工作的数据类型，你必须支持一个至少可以是左单位元的单位元操作。所以，你需要一个元素，你可以拿那个元素
But also then if you're tiling it up and doing it in a single pass, you have to do some trickiness to handle the beginning and the end of each tile. And at one point, I thought that there might, there's this thing in Cub called block discontinuity, which I think is how you would do this if you were doing it in Cub. But I just wanted to write this straight in standard C++.
然后做那个元素加某物，你总是得到某物。你需要这个的原因是，你会有一些临时变量，一旦你拆分了数据，每个线程都会将东西累加到临时变量中，然后与其他线程通信。在像解耦回溯扫描（decoupled lookback scan）这样的情况下，你不仅会有线程内的那些临时变量，
All these algorithms, everything in my talk is implemented purely in standard C++ parallel algorithms. But yeah, I was eventually able to sort of crack that aspect of it. And I'm not sure, did we talk, when we talked about Shunk Buy, I know I posited a solution for how we could hung up on the fact that we were digging, we were going down the rabbit hole of looking at the reduce by key thrust algorithms and whether or not those were implemented with, I think we determined that it was implemented with a inclusive scan by key. And then we were talking about whether you could implement it as a reduce i think that's where we kind of left stuff right right well it turns out you can do chunk by with the scan um and the key intuition that one must realize to get to the chunk by with the scan
而且你会有创建、存储并在不同线程间通信的临时变量，它们会以有趣的方式相加来实现这种解耦回溯机制，这是一个我们应该讨论的完整独立的播客剧集，也会在我的演讲中涵盖。但为了让这一切工作，你需要能够有一个“无”对象，你可以把它加到某物上并得到同样的某物。我的代码的原始版本在导入到单次扫描版本后无法正常工作，因为我没有考虑这个单位元的问题。我没有以一种
is that first you must realize that you could implement chunk by with multiple scans. Like if I could do like three scans, three very simple scans, I could do chunk by. It might be inefficient, but three very simple scans and I could do it. You know, like I could do scan, i could do a scan to figure out um uh you know how many groups they're going to be and what the indexes those groups are going to be and then i could do a scan to figure out the you know the start and the end of each one of those groups or i could do one scan to figure out the start and one scan to figure out the end and all of those would be fairly simple scans and then the only tricky part that you're presented with is how do I write a single scan that does
我可以把一个“无”的东西加到它上面，仍然得到单位元的方式定义操作。所以后来我不得不坐下来，那是我在寿司店那个晚上得到的洞察，我需要有一个单位元操作。然后我还有另一个洞察，只是关于我如何在扫描中重置特定计数的洞察。所以有时在扫描中，你在计数，在某个点，你可能想重置它们。比如，做一个只计算所有东西的扫描非常简单，对吧？那就像一个带有加法操作的扫描。那只是我们典型的扫描。好吧，也许这不是表达它的方式。比如，如果你做一个扫描，你有一个整数加法，
all three of those scans at the same time? And that also does the flag setting part too. And that is where the challenging part is. Because then you have to define your own new data type. And then you have to define an operator on that data type, a reduction operator on that data type that does the right thing. And one of the places where I got hung up a good bit is on the identity operation, that I defined my data type, and then I defined my plus operator on that data type, and I defined it in a way that it worked. However, to define a data type that's going to work correctly with a parallel scan, you have to support a identity operation that, at the very least, can be a left identity. So, you need some element that you can take that element
每个元素都被转换成 1，那就会给你一个计数。抱歉，我刚才说到哪了？哦，是的，是的。所以有时你想用扫描做点什么，你有一个重置条件。我在为 Chunk Buy 正确设置重置条件时遇到了困难，比如我什么时候为下一个块重置这个计数？但后来在某个时候我意识到，我在我的区间类型中追踪了另一条信息。那条信息是索引是什么，输出中的当前索引，比如我在第几组？你明白吗？你需要追踪的事情之一是我到目前为止创建了多少个块？是的，有道理。是的。是的。所以，好的。然后我意识到，啊哈，如果我有我当前所在的任何块的索引，
and do that element plus something, and you always get back something. And the reason that you need that is because you're going to have some temporaries that each, you know, once you split up your data, you're going to have some temporaries that each thread is going to accumulate stuff into and then communicate to the other threads. And in the case of something like a decoupled lookback scan, you're not going to only have those temporaries
那么我可以很容易地看出什么时候需要重置，因为我所要做的就是说，嗯，索引，比如如果我有两个元素 L 和 R，如果 L 的索引和 R 的索引不同，那么我就到了需要重置的地方。需要注意的是，如果其中一个索引为零，有一个特殊情况，因为你可能在右边累加了一些东西。这就像一个局部的东西。但这就是让我得到正确解决方案的基本想法，而不是我之前做的那个，那个要复杂得多，而且是有状态的，而且根本行不通。好吧，听起来这将是一个超级有趣的演讲。我是说，我想到的事情之一……
within a thread, but then you're going to have temporaries that will get created and stored and communicated across different threads and will get added up in interesting ways to implement this decoupled look back mechanism, which is a whole separate podcast episode we should talk about and will also be covered in my talk. But for all of that to work, you need to be able to have a nothing object that you can add to something and get back that same something. And the original version of my code didn't work correctly once I imported it to the single pass version because I had not thought about this question of like an identity element. And I did not have the operation defined in a way
我担心你可能是唯一能听懂的人。不，我不认为那是真的。绝对，我们应该……我担心你可能是唯一能听懂的人。不，我不认为那是真的。绝对，我们应该……我想他之前肯定在播客中出现过，我们只是还没联系他，我们应该请 Bartosz Milewski，因为我们一直在为“单位元值”之类的术语而挣扎。但所有这些东西都有名字，你基本上指的是幺半群（monoid）。然后我甚至查了一下。我在想，什么是需要交换性的幺半群？ChatGPT 或更准确地说是 GPT-4 说，这些被称为交换幺半群或阿贝尔幺半群。
where I could add a nothing thing to it and still get back the identity. And so then I had to sit down and that was sort of the insight that I had the night that I was at the sushi place was that I needed to have some identity operation. And then I had one other insight, which was just sort of an insight about how I could reset a particular count in a scan. So sometimes in a scan, you're counting things, and at some point, you might want to reset them. Like, you know, like, it's very simple to do, like, a scan that just, like, counts all of the things, right? That's just like a scan with, like, you know, a plus operation. That's just sort of our typical scan. Well, maybe that's not a way to put it. Like, if you do a scan where you have an integer plus
所以基本上 std reduce 需要的是一个阿贝尔幺半群。我实际上认为在这个特定情况下，我实际上不需要它是可交换的，因为扫描是非交换的，因为它保证事情是从左到右完成的，我实际上只需要它是左单位元，这个单位元元素只需要在操作的左侧时起作用。有趣。在我的演讲中要注意的一件事是，我的代码在 GitHub 上。如果你去 GitHub 上看代码，要注意的一件事是每当有加法或扫描操作时。
and where every element is transformed into, you know, one, then that'll give you a count. Sorry, where was I? Oh, yes, yes. So sometimes you want to do something with a scan where you have some reset condition. And I was having difficulty getting the reset condition correct for chunk by, like when do I reset this count for the next chunk? But then at some point I realized that I had this other piece of information that I was tracking in my interval type. And that piece of information was what is the index, the current index of like in the output, like what number group am I on? You follow? Like one of the things that you need to keep track of is how many chunks have I created thus far? Yeah, makes sense. Yeah. Yeah. And so, okay. And so then I realized, aha, if I have the index of whatever chunk I'm currently on,
在我的代码示例中，为了简单起见，我只使用了加法。但每当有扫描操作时，左边是什么，右边是什么的选择是非常非常有目的性的。在某些地方，它看起来很不直观。比如有几个地方你可能会看代码，你会想，为什么他用赋值操作符和加法，而不是用加等于？原因是那里用加等于会以错误的顺序做事情。它会把应该在左边的东西放在右边。我相当确定我在所有地方都做对了。而且我认为如果我没做对，代码
then I can tell when I need to reset easily because all I have to do is say, hmm, has the index, like if I have two elements, L and R, if the index of L is different than the index of R, then I'm at a place where I need to reset. With the caveat being that there's a special case if one of them has an index of zero because you may be accumulating something on the right. It's like a local thing. But that's the basic idea that got me to the correct solution, as opposed to the thing that I was doing prior to that, which was far more complicated and stateful, and just simply didn't work. Well, it sounds like it's going to be a super interesting talk. I mean, one of the things that I thought about...
就不会工作，因为我为 Chunk Buy 使用的数据类型根本不是可交换的，我相信。元素乘以你的类型等于同一个类型，它说这通常被称为左单位元幺半群，是的，我会……GPT-4 是在编造吗，还是事实确实如此？我相信外面有范畴论专家，这就是为什么我们请 Bartosz，因为可能对范畴论知情的人来说……这就是问题所在，我读完了他的书。所以当我听到你说，哦，这是一种类型，但我没有定义这个“无”，你知道，所有这些东西实际上已经……你知道，有范畴论支持它。所有这些东西都有名字，如果我们打算……如果我们打算这样做，我们应该尽力去了解这些名字。说出来让我很痛苦。
I fear that you may be the only person that'll understand it. No, I don't think that's true at all. Definitely, we should, one of the people that i thought about i i fear that you may be the only person that'll understand it no i i don't think that's true at all definitely we should one of the people that i thought that i think it's he's come up on the podcast before for sure we just haven't reached out to him we should have on bartaj maluski because we are struggling through the terminology of like identity value and stuff but all of this stuff has names like you're referring to basically as a monoid. And then I even looked it up. I was like, what is a monoid that requires commutativity? And ChatGPT or GPT-4 to be precise said that those are referred to as commutative monoids or abelian monoids.
尤其是在我母亲能听到的范围内说出来，这让我很痛苦。但这是我大学教育实际上教了我一些有用的东西的罕见时刻之一。对于那些不知道的人，我第一次大学辍学了。但后来第二次，我在 LSU 工作，是一名兼职学生，最终在那里获得了学位。我的学位是应用数学。我实际上认为如果不是因为意识到我遇到的问题是我没有足够的……如果不是因为我实际的数学训练，我可能早就卡住并放弃这个问题了。所以是的，有些东西我认为我在学校学到了。一旦我有了那个认识，
So basically what std reduce requires is an abelian monoid. And I actually think that in this particular case that I actually don't need it to be commutative that in particular it's an I only need because scan is non-commutative because it guarantees that things are going to be done from left to right, I only actually need it to be like a left identity, that this identity element only has to work when it's on the left-hand side of the operation. Interesting. And one thing to watch for in my talk, and I have the code on GitHub. If you go and look on the code on GitHub, one thing to watch for is whenever there is an addition or a scan operation.
我就做了一件事，每隔几个月左右，工作中就会出现一些需要我去运用数学的事情。这就是我在寿司店做的事情。一旦我有了那个认识，我就想，好吧，我要坐下来，我不会把它当作数学，我能以一种非常抽象的伪代码方式定义这些操作吗？然后我能得出一个证明这行得通的结论吗？我在纽约公寓的某个地方有那张寿司店的纸，我在上面做了证明。好吧，伙计们，你们听到了。有很多值得期待的事情。如果你在 ACCU，嗯，你的演讲是在周五之前还是之后？是在周五。
In my code examples, I just use addition for simplicity. But whenever there's a scan operation, the choice of which thing is on the left and which thing is on the right is very, very purposeful. And in some places, it seems unintuitive. Like there's a couple places where you might look at the code and you might be like, well, why is he using assignment operator and plus instead of using plus equals? And the reason is that using plus equals there would do things in the wrong order. It would put the thing that should be on the left on the right. And I'm fairly certain that I got it correct in all the places. And I think if I didn't get it correct, the code
是在周五。是周五吗？周五。在下午？比布里斯托尔早六个小时，对吧？是的。是的。这个播客会在演讲前播出，哦，太完美了，所以你知道
would not work because the data type that I'm using for chunk by is not at all commutative, I believe. element times your type equals that same type and it says that this is typically referred to as a left identity monoid which yeah i would do is gpt4 making that up or does it actually the case i'm sure there's someone that's a category theory expert out there but uh which is why we just bring on bartage because probably to the category theory informed person. And that's the thing is I worked my way through his book. And so when I hear you saying like, oh, it's a type, but I didn't, I didn't define this like nothing, you know, all of this stuff is actually already like there's a, you know, category theory for it. And all this stuff has names, and we should do our best to try and know those names if we're going to be. It pains me to say it.
如果你恰好在 ACCU，就去听 Bryce 的演讲，如果没有，链接会在节目说明中，等它上线时查看。我们会得到关于……我确实想回到我担心我的演讲不被理解的恐惧，嗯，我担心我做演讲时会失去听众。或者我知道我失去了听众。这很有趣，因为一方面，我认为让我成为一个好演讲者的原因之一是我尽量不预设太多的知识，我尽量从第一性原理出发做事情。我认为这是
And it pains me especially to say it with my mother in earshot. But this is one of those rare times when my college education actually taught me something useful. For those who are unaware, I dropped out of college the first time. But then the second time, I was working at LSU and was a student part-time and then eventually got a degree there. And my degree was in applied math. And I actually think I would have been stuck and given up on this problem if not for the realization that the issue that I was having was that I did not have a sufficient, that I could not from my actual math schooling. So yeah, there is something that I think I learned in school. And as soon as I had that realization,
我在科技界这段时间取得成功的原因之一，我认为是我在展示事物时不预设太多知识的愿望。但另一方面，我可以感觉到并看到我什么时候失去了听众，什么时候我讲得太快了。当事情对我来说似乎是一组非常非常明显的结论时，并不一定对每个人都适用。我确实有时担心我失去了听众，而且我没有充分传达我的想法。是的，我不会太担心。只要是那些不认为自己正在失去听众的人……就像，你知道，疯子不担心自己疯了。
I did something that like every now and then, every couple of months or so, there's a time where I come across something in work that requires me to go and do math. And that's what I was doing at the sushi restaurant. I was like, once I had that realization, I was like, all right, I'm going to sit down and I'm going to approach this not as a math, can I define these operations in a very abstract, pseudocode-y fashion? And then can I come up with a proof that this works? And I do somewhere in my apartment in New York have the sushi restaurant paper where I did the proof. Well, there you have it, folks. Lots to look forward to. If you're at ACCU, well, when is your talk before or after Friday? It's going to be Friday.
或者不，等等。是的，是的。就是这样。就像如果你认为自己疯了，你可能没疯。这意味着至少它在你的雷达上。我知道我一直在失去听众，当我开始谈论你知道的组合子层次结构和组合逻辑时，很多人在评论中指出，但我最喜欢的视频评论之一是，你知道，在我的日常工作中没用，有点令人困惑，但我欣赏这家伙的热情。
It's going to be Friday. Is it Friday? Friday. In the afternoon? Six hours ahead, Bristol, right? Yes. Yes. This podcast will air before the talk oh perfect uh so you know
就像他显然很兴奋，而且，你知道，只要我觉得他们能够学到一些东西，即使他们最终在某个点迷路了，我是说，我看过很多演讲，不是因为演讲者做得不好，而是因为为了跟上所需的必要知识，我当时没有。然后你回去，以后再看他们的演讲，它可能会产生影响，比如你不是只理解了 10%，而是理解了 90%，所以，你只是希望你把中级或专家标签贴上，然后人们就不会失望了。是的，我几乎总是这样做。是的。是的。但这也是那种事情之一，
go to bryce's talk if you happen to be at accu if not link will be in the show notes for when it goes online we'll get an update on on i do want to circle back to my my fear that that my talks are not understood which um i i fear that i lose people when i give talks. Or I know that I lose people. And it's funny because on the one hand, I think one of the things that makes me a good speaker is that I try not to have too much assumed knowledge and I try to do things very from first principles. And I think that's one of the things
就像，我想我几乎不了解这些东西是如何以及为什么工作的。Chunk Buy 其实没那么糟糕。对于 Chunk Buy，我认为理解起来相当简单。对于滚动归约那个，
that's been successful throughout my time in tech I think has been my desire to not assume too much knowledge when presenting things. But on the other hand, I can feel and see when I'm losing people and when I'm moving too fast. And when things seem like very, very obvious set of conclusions to me does not necessarily track for everybody. And I do I do sometimes worry that that I lose people and that and that I'm not sufficiently communicating my ideas. Yeah, I wouldn't be too worried about it. As long as it's the people who don't think they're losing folks. It's like, you know, crazy people aren't worried about being crazy.
滚动归约的东西有一个组件，我有一种心理模型来理解它是如何工作的，但也许我没有。我无法解释它是如何工作的。它确实有效。一旦我看到它是如何工作的，就像，哦，是的，那说得通。但我无法向你解释一个人是如何从问题走到这就是你应该编写解决方案的方式的。是的，太可惜了。那是我们丢失的剧集之一，非常有趣。但总之，也许我们会重温它。
Or no, wait. Yeah, yeah. That's exactly it. It's like if you think you're crazy, you're probably not crazy. Meaning that at least it's on your radar i know all the time that i'm losing folks when i start talking about you know the hierarchy of combinators and combinatory logic and a bunch of folks pointed out in the comments but like one of my favorite comments on one of these videos was like you know not useful in my day job and was a bit confusing but uh i appreciate the guy's enthusiasm
哦，我们丢失了那个？哦，是的。是的。我们肯定会在某个时候重温它，因为在某个时候我要做一个关于滚动归约的演讲。为了做那个演讲，我必须想出一个解释。总之，所以，我是说，如果这要在周五的剧集中播出，我想我们应该提到，如果你想见 Bryce 的妈妈，她会在周五参加他的演讲。而且你理论上可以在我的演讲后找到她和我。
like he's clearly excited and uh you know as long as i feel like yeah they are able to pick up something even if they end up getting lost at some point i mean there's tons of talks that i've watched not because necessarily the presenter was doing a bad job but the requisite knowledge that you needed in order to be able to keep up i just didn't have at the time and then you go back you watch their talk later and potentially it hits like in instead of only understanding 10 you understand 90 so it's uh you just hopefully you put you know at least intermediate or expert on the label and then people won't be disappointed yeah i pretty much always do. Yeah. Yeah. But it's also like one of those things
所以是的，去听 Bryce 的演讲，去见 Bryce 的妈妈。好的，我会把这段话剪辑回第一集。而且他们必须……你得知道他们必须是，我不知道你怎么称呼他们。一个狂热的听众，因为当播客上线到你的演讲开始之间可能只有很短的时间窗口，所以我如果有人在演讲后走过来，我会真心感到印象深刻。
where it's like, I think I barely have an understanding of how and why these things work. It's not so bad for chunk buy, actually. For chunk buy, I think it's pretty straightforward to understand. For the rolling reduction one,
提到他们听过这一集。是的，我甚至认为这不会发生，因为他们会在会议上。可能会有一个奖品。我会这么说。如果你做了，有一个奖品。有一个奖品。好的，伙计们，你们在这里第一次听到了。你的演讲到底是什么时候？上午 11 点。
there's a component of the rolling reduction thing that I's a component of the rolling reduction thing that I kind of have a mental model for how it works, but maybe I don't. I cannot explain how it works. It works. Once I see how it works, it's sort of like, oh yeah, that makes sense. But I cannot explain to you how one gets from the problem to this is how you should write the solution. Yeah, it's too bad. That was one of the episodes we lost, which was quite entertaining. But anyways, maybe we'll revisit that.
好的，不。伦敦时间。我告诉过你，兄弟。我告诉过你。时差是五个小时。播客在美东时间上午 9 点发布。你能破例吗？当然，为什么不呢？
Oh, we lost that? Oh, yeah. Yeah. We'll definitely revisit it at some point because at some point I'm going to give a talk about rolling reduce. And to give that talk, I'm going to have to come up with an explanation. Anyways, so I mean, if this is going to go in the episode on Friday, I guess we should mention that if you want to meet Bryce's mom, she'll be at his talk on Friday. And you could, in theory, find her and me, uh, after my talk.
我会在 ACCU 当地时间上午 9 点发布它，那会是，那是什么，早五个或六个小时？好吧，你知道吗？当然。你可能可以安排它。我可能可以，但是的，我会研究一下。我会让它发生的，伙计们。如果我必须在凌晨 3 点起床，这不是我为 ADSP 做过的最困难的事情。一定要在你的播客应用或 ADSPthepodcast.com 查看这些节目说明，
So yeah, go to Bryce's talk, get to meet Bryce's mom. All right. I will, I will splice this back into the first episode. Uh, and, and they'll have to be, you'll know that they'll have to be like, uh, I don't know what you call them. An avid listener listener because there's probably a short window of time when when the uh the podcast goes live and then your talk starts so i will like i will be genuinely impressed if somebody comes up to me after the talk and
获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息碎片的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
mentions that they have listened to this episode yeah i, I don't even think it'll happen because they'll be at the conference. There might be a prize. I'll say this. If you do, there's a prize. There is a prize. All right, you heard it here first, folks. And what time actually is your talk at? 11 a.m.
提到他们听过这一集，是的，我觉得这不太可能发生，因为他们那时会在参加会议。可能会有一个奖品。我这么说吧，如果你做了，就有奖品。确实有奖品。好了，各位，你们在这里先听到了。你的演讲具体是什么时间？上午11点。
Okay, no. London time. I told you, bro. I told you. The time difference is five hours. The podcast gets released at 9 a.m. EST. Could you make an exception? Sure, why not?
好吧，不，是伦敦时间。我告诉过你了，兄弟。我告诉过你了。时差是五个小时。播客是在东部标准时间上午9点发布的。你能破例一下吗？当然，为什么不呢？
I will release it at 9 a.m. local time for ACCU, which will be, what is that, five or six hours earlier? Well, you know what? Sure. You could probably schedule it. I probably could, but yeah, I'll look into it. I'll make it happen, folks. If I have to wake up at 3 a.m., it's not the most difficult thing I've had to do for ADSP. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com
我会按照ACCU的当地时间上午9点发布，那会是，大概提前五六个小时？好吧，你知道吗？没问题。你大概可以安排一下。我大概可以，是的，我会研究一下。我会做到的，各位。如果我必须在凌晨3点起床，这也不是我为ADSP做过的最困难的事情。请务必在你的播客应用中或访问ADSPthepodcast.com查看这些节目说明，
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以让你留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。